we are asked how many proportional
relationships are shown in the
coordinate plane below and we have the
choices but let's actually look at the
coordinate plane below to think about
how many proportional relationships are
depicted here so pause this video and
try to answer that yourself
so let's do this together
so if we're thinking about a
proportional relationship or the graph
of a proportional relationship there
should be two things that we're looking
for
one it should be a line it should be a
linear relationship between the two
variables y should be some constant some
proportionality constant times x
so you immediately would rule out our
green curve here because this is not a
line you don't have a constant
relationship between y being some
proportional
y being some proportionality constant
times x
and for the same reason you would rule
out this blue curve now what about this
purple line this might be tempting
because it is a line but it does not go
through the origin when x is 2 y is 0
times x
while when x is 4 y is 1 times x and
when
x is 6
y looks to be
1 1 3 times x so you don't have the same
proportionality constant the entire time
so we have zero proportional
relationships depicted here so i would
pick 0 there
let's do one more example
natalie is an expert archer the
following table shows her scores points
based on the number of targets she hits
all right targets hit and then the
points she gets plot the order pairs
from the table all right so the first
one is one comma three
so here i'm doing it on khan academy my
horizontal axis is targets hit
and my vertical axis is points
so
one target hit three points so this is
going to be
one target hit this is going to be three
points
then i have two targets hit six points
so two targets hit
and i have six points
and then i'm gonna have through or five
targets hit 15 points
so then i'm going to have
going to have
five targets hit
and
that is going to be 15 points
and so this is looking like a
proportional relationship in every
situation my point is equal to three
times the target's hit so my
proportionality constant is three and
you can see if you try to connect these
dots with a line it will be a line a
line can go through all three of these
and it will go through the origin
so are natalie's points proportional to
the number of targets she hit
yes absolutely